thank you very much for your time thank
you very much
andre solditoff and irina boragon
co-founders of the news website
ajintora.ru discussed the reinvention of
the kgb during vladimir putin's tenure
as russia's president
the authors speak at the new america
foundation in washington d.c
the program is a little over an hour
all right i think we're going to
get started and i'll send a limo out for
anybody that couldn't get through here
on the metro my name is
david hoffman and i'm a contributing
editor of foreign policy magazine
uh foreign policy and the new america
foundation are co-hosting this event
today and i would just like to say thank
you very much to everyone from new
america foundation that helped make this
possible uh you know they certainly are
interested in getting more and more uh
visitors coming and speaking here and
they really
did a lot of things to help us put this
together in a short period of time
i was in an earlier period the moscow
correspondent for the washington post
and those of us who remember a little
bit back what it was like to be a
correspondent
even before me in the times of soviet
union will recall that correspondence
were prohibited from
going more than 25 miles outside of
moscow without permission from the
authorities it was a very
difficult and stultifying environment
and i know peter osnos was here with us
today who published this book was a
correspondent in that time and
remembers it even more vividly than i do
and even after the soviet collapse when
i was correspondent in yeltsin's time
there were
also many many risks to being a
correspondent
since 2017 russian journalists have been
killed including
anakovskaya and many others now
bow
sometimes
on their own and sometimes under
coercion to the new authoritarianism
today i think we have a chance to talk
to two journalists who are working in
today's russia in this environment
and what makes
them special
is that they are real digging
investigative reporters
and they are determined to ferret out
facts
to judge them to
check them
and in especially they're doing this in
one of the most difficult fields that is
to report today i know from my own
experience the security services
are very very opaque and secretive
andrei soldatov and irina borigan are
co-founders of their own
website agentura.ru
and i would mention to you that there's
a very nice and easy to navigate new
english version of this website where
you can go and see a lot of their work
it's a rather
new
media way to carry out their
investigations when they write some of
their articles which are also published
in russia they also post them so people
can have access to
what they found as they as they pursue
their investigations
andre
worked for novi gazietta from 2006 to
2008 and both of them have told me
that they
both of us
both of you were yeah yes and you also
both worked at other russian newspapers
as well including the
long lamented newspaper savonia started
by vladimir klusinski back after
the collapse of the union
anyway again twitter rule has
distinguished itself by posting
information about the security services
and has their work has also been
featured in many many other western
publications and i uh
noted that the new york times in a
headline called it a website that came
in from the cold to unveil russian
secrets so
we're here today to talk about their new
book um this is it i'll just so everyone
can see the really nice looking cover
and the picture of the lubianca on the
front of it the new nobility the
restoration of russia's security state
and the enduring legacy of the kgb and
i'd just like to introduce the book very
briefly
then we'll have a lot of questions for
them and they're eager certainly to
address whatever you'd like to ask them
about
in 1994
the journalist evgenia albats published
a book called the state within a state
and her work was finished just as the
soviet union was collapsing
all bots intended her book as a kind of
a wake-up call
that even though the soviet union had
collapsed the kgb was still surviving in
fact she said not only surviving
but thriving
and the best evidence that her alarm
about
this was
to be taken seriously
is the work that andre and rina present
to us today
because theirs is really the first
major investigation of the impact of
these security services and their
activities since
evgenia's book more than 15 years ago
for most of the last decade particularly
under president and now prime minister
putin it's been a very eventful time for
these security services
the new nobility tells us how
the head of the fsb
the federal security service the main
successor agency referred
to
his associates and their services
the new nobility from which the title of
the book is taken
and one of the things we want to talk
about today is
what did the security services do
with these blessings of resources and
prestige and responsibility that putin
gave them
how did they respond to the challenges
of terrorism and what role have they had
in enforcing the new authoritarianism
and in suppressing dissent
have the security services widen their
operations to include overseas
extrajudicial killings
and what else have they been doing in
this dark world
now a brief word about acronyms
the kgb is all familiar to you from
soviet times
the main successor
to the kgb the domestic successor
supposedly was the federal security
services
russian and this was our fsb so today
we'll be talking a lot about the fsb
and of course we'll see that they've
grown greatly in stature and they
weren't entirely
domestic successor but there is a
foreign intelligence agency also
with the initials svr if that comes up
they're also successor to the kgb and
there are other agencies which i hope
andre and arena will tell us about and
help us distinguish and sort out
so
i
hope that we have a really fun and
interesting productive
hour
a little bit more than an hour with them
i'd like to remind everybody that we're
taping and filming everything is on the
record
and
you know please state your questions
clearly but we're a small group so we
have time i think if you have a
follow-up if if you didn't if you want
to follow up please let me know i'll try
and be a
honest broker and fair moderator
and uh i guess i'll be the guy to start
us off by asking the first question but
i
then i'll turn it over and open it up
and i guess andre and irina both of you
i'd like to ask you
one of your uh basic arguments for this
book and for your findings is that the
fsb
uh didn't become a small shriveled piece
of the kgb it actually became bigger in
some ways much more uh powerful and
independent than the kgb could you
explain how how did this happen and why
uh well of course in in in terms of
numbers uh of personal fsb is still
uncomparable within kgb because the kgb
or the security service of the soviet
union and soviet union was much
bigger than russia
but if we are talking about the
influence and how we
changed political culture of russia and
how they controllable by the by the
society and by the kremlin uh well i
think that we can say that now the fsb
is more powerful
firstly because the kgb be no powerful
organization was always a kind of tool
for soviet communist party and at the
same time
the communist party of soviet union
uh
fully controls the kgb because there was
special
party cells so-called apache cells in
every department division or section of
the kgb
and
for the fsb of course when in 1991 the
soviet union collapsed
uh
the idea was to replace by something uh
this body control and the initial idea
of yields and was to create a federal
rivalry inside the intelligence
community and to have arrivals for
example where the fsb uh
com comp uh competed with uh
communication agency foxy which is maybe
comparable vfr u.s national security
agency buffy
one very important thing
fabsi was also responsible for
monitoring social and political
situation in in russian regions so
that's why yeltsin has the ability to
compare report of the fsb director with
the report of the pharmacy director at
the same time
foreign intelligence svr what you
mentioned
competed with military intelligence so
in this world of
of competitive rivalry competition jason
has the possibility to compare different
reports
information provided by the security
services and he had
an impression that he might control all
this
uh of a system of intelligent services
what was done by
by vladimir putin he made the federal
security service the fsb the main
security service of russia
and he allowed
the fsb to absorb some parts of the kgb
first of all
uh the significant part of fab c of the
of the old travel com of this
communication agency border troops
and uh
even when the fsb can could not absorb
some secret services for example
foreign intelligence
uh putin downloads fsb to get
more of more powers and to create their
own
department responsible for government
intelligence abroad
and
so so now the fsb if we are talking
about wave functions they might be
comparable with the kgb but at the same
time we are more powerful because we
are there is no mechanism to control
this big security service because
another problem is that the
fsb is not for example uh we cannot
compare the fmi5 of of the breaches
because it's not just apparatus but not
just personnel based in moscow but we
have a big regional structure in every
russian regions and every russian cities
very special department and branch and
there is no tools to control all these
people
that's why uh
maybe the first and
i think it's a quite striking thing that
uh
fsb people they
uh love to talk about tyrion drop off
but juran dropper was the longest chief
of the kgb he was when he was a he
became a chief of russian state of
soviet state so he was
a very he is a kind of hero for the fsb
but we should say uh that euron dropper
was never a trained kgb agent he was
operatic he was a par he was uh um he
was an official uh of the politburo and
he was sent by politburo to oversee the
activity of the kgb at the same time we
have now the country and vladimir putin
trained kgb and fsb agent
um led the country for
80 years as a president and now he's a
prime minister
under just uh let me ask a follow-up
here then
did this really begin with putin or did
it even begin sooner
no it's because it's been
i think it's begun in
early ireland me already in the mid
1990s uh for example
prisons
and investigative uh departments of the
fsb were returned to the fsb in 1995
and the unit responsible for political
surveillance was resurrected in 1998 so
it was long before putin became
prominent
why don't we
have some questions and i'll keep
interjecting if i can please
we have a microphone we can you just
everybody speak to the microphone please
we'll bring it to you
and please give your name to a few
uh good morning my name is anthony i'm a
consultant on economic development uh
andre nirena could you talk a little bit
about your sources
how do you two
as independent journalists find out what
is going on in these opaque secretive
agencies
frankly speaking it's very difficult to
find sources inside secret services uh
right now in russia um because of all
all russian policies are so secretive
especially and sphere of secrets of the
secret services but we started to work
uh in
1996 uh so things were so openly the
journalists and
uh they started covered this
uh this issues in uh into in 1999 in
and so at that time you can uh you could
find a lot of sources inside this
russian secret sauce services uh
so it's
of course it's the difference between uh
secret services in the usa and russia
because you can take uh some official
official documents and official
information from leadership of the
secret of the american secret services
but it's impossible in russia very
difficult
they are
absolutely
ignorable to the journalists uh even in
the case of official request because and
so
you should work hard with low rank
offices inside the sacred sources and
and
with middle ranking officers as they
might be very very useful and
you should use the information but
the question is how to check this
information and you should do you should
do double checked because uh
sometimes they wanted to use
journalists in their own purposes they
might be sent to journalists by their
leadership
uh what happened with us
well in 2002 we understood when there
was a big issue when we there was a
criminal investigation against us
because we were suspected to
to disclose some secrets and i had a
source inside the moscow department of
the fsb
and i thought that it was all our
relationship are
as unofficial but when he started to
propose me some to suggest some some
ideas that we can stop these
investigations if you can stop writing
something but let's understand he is
always under control and for me it was
quite depressing but today the situation
has started to change again because
there was a period maybe for eight seven
years so that it was
maybe impossible to get new sources
inside but last three four years now
an important thing right now there's a
gap and a big
even i think it's a big internal crisis
instead inside the fsb it's a crisis
between
it's a problem between low ranking
officials and generals because flooring
and officials we are so depressed but
they got
it have uh
a low level of sellers they are not so
protected they are not given these
privileges and uh that
generals for granted so now they they
started for example to sue
the leadership of the fs being cars and
we have now some complaints even in
strasbourg human rights
uh called
of the fsb officers against the
leadership
and the at least one case was i was
decided in february of this office of
safesb and now russian russian state
should pay this officer
i think 14 14 000 euros
uh
because
they found that he was right against his
leadership that's but with my help
my name is katie lesova school of
foreign service georgetown university
first of all i wanted to thank you for
the book i listened to through
audible.com it was very nice to find it
there thank you so much
um and um if you find me i have two
questions first question is
it seems that this restoration you're
talking about uh happened to with the
support of the major part of the russian
population
so what should happen my question is
what should happen for that support to
wither to weaken
and the second question is
it's regarding your profile andre your
profile on
open source
center
media
and it says that
um they guessed that the fact that you
can operate with the relative freedom in
russia despite the hot topic you're
covering because of your father's ties
to the russian security services
so and actually they also point out that
in 2008 vladimir putin appointed your
father as a deputy communications
minister yeah so could you please
comment on this too yeah okay the first
question is um
why russian population support uh the
fsb first of all
the fsb is much more selective and the
kgb used to be
dealing with population so we have now a
number of troublemakers of course it's
yeah islamists and the north caucasus so
some people who might be politically
active
uh who have some for example who
want to create some horizontal
structures some for example to
uh to combat government decisions about
him care forest or some some local
initiative all these people
all these initiative
initiatives are considered to be
uh quite
um suspicious by the fsb but only these
people would be under uh
would be
under under control
by the fsb so for the most of population
we
they might deal with the interior
ministry and we you know it's there is a
big outcry about the interior ministry
corruption but not about the fsb just
because
fsb is more selective
and at the same time the fsb was very
very skillful to deal with public
opinion now they
they understood to be frank it it
happened already in 2002 2003 when the
students would it's much more
effective not to answer questions of
journalists
but to produce directly
variations of events directly to the
public and they
just be happy to produce some movies and
not only the commentaries but fiction
movies uh very explained the actual for
example terrorist attacks and we have
for example the movie called lich
ninomer and in english it's countdown
with
and and and the plot of this of this
movie is to is to talk this to tell
about two
most
catastrophic terrorist attacks in moscow
i mean
1999 moscow partners bombings and nordos
hostage
and
in 2002
and but in case of
in the movie you can see that the man
here is fsb officer
and the main mastermind of all terrorist
attacks is russian oligarch named
pokrovsky who live in exile in london so
so
it's understandable and this movie was
uh there is no secret that this movie
was advised by deputy director of the
fsb and was supported by the fsb
uh your your second question about my
father uh
my father in the 1990s he was advised to
communication agency pepsi and he was
responsible for
creating a kind of
uh safe uh internet for government
communications
uh so it was not about intelligence work
and uh in 1998 in 2008 he was
appointed uh as a deputy deputy minister
of communications
but the problem is that
since 2006
his company who supported our website
since 2000 2000 to 2006
it with support of the gintura and uh
that's why
i learned about his appointment when
albuquerque responded called me
uh so i think i'm
i'm not responsible and my father is not
responsible for my activity and i'm not
responsible for activity of my father
well and to to talk about my my personal
things my personal secrets i can say
that we both were interrogated many
times by the fsb first time in 2002
as the last time in 2008
uh
so
i don't feel
i don't think i have to
to feel sorry but i'm not killed
peter
mary asked you both to uh
grab the microphone peter
publisher
excuse me i'm the publisher
of the book in it
um
i'm just very interested in how
i i've forgotten how old you are but
whatever it is it's very young
25 to 6 35 36 and i'm sort of sick
so you're old enough
to remember
the old
soviet union
and i often wonder what young people
like you
imagined would happen
when the soviet union
collapsed imploded
and
what what you think of this world it's
after all a world which russia created
for itself
it wasn't opposed upon it there was no
invasion
whatever anybody may think
it wasn't ronald reagan and margaret
thatcher who took down the soviet union
it ended on its own
and i and i wonder what your generation
believed you would find in 2010
and then
where you think it's going
you know you can see and we often do
that you could take communism
out of russia turns out communism was
kind of a parenthesis
for 70 years between the old russia and
the new russia which were really very
quite similar i wonder
what you think
russia will become
so
what did you think it would be
when you were
let's see now 15 or so
teenagers rebellious
what you thought russia would be
versus what it's become
and what you think will happen
next
say 15 years from now when we next
meet
here in this in this room in europe by
then 51 and oh my goodness okay
all right
well uh
in 1991 when the various offices felt
couped i went to
to to
to the to the hotel moscow and there was
a
lines of tanks and
people were so
so angry about this
it looks like invasion because justin
and just you get a peaceful city and you
see all these all these tanks and we
were all excited but
uh when two to two days after that uh
there was a real victory for us for me
personally it was i was still in school
but for me it was very very important
because i understood that the countries
would be more open i can go abroad i can
talk to my i can find
people and friends and in other
countries and when we thought it would
be something
do we think we were very naive and first
of all our parents were very very naive
they thought that
we just can't create the same united
states
they always talked there was a special
movie even by
by govardhan why russia is not the
united states something like that and uh
there are some signs that you see that
our policeman is not like the
the policeman in the united states so we
have to do something to well the idea
was to create something similar to to to
to to the way of living in the united
states mostly in the united states
because united states was for us it's a
kind of sign of
of of freedom and of this open world and
but
uh in the 19 in the late 1990s
especially after 1998 financial crisis
as a middle class and i remember it very
well because when i worked for
i worked for for paper but i covered
financial things so i
dealt with financial journalist and i
remember how all these financial
journals who were so pro-western anxiety
they all
spoke english and they all
looked for for the financial times of
ostrich resolution as an example
all started to be so depressed and so
disappointed so disillusioned they
started to talk well
it looks like we we we've done all
we've done all our career uh how it
should be but now we felt so might be
something from the first western model
maybe it's this western model fit only
only the west we need to to to invent
something
something russian and there was a many
uh for example
i think most people just forgot forgot
about it but there was a campaign in in
moscow to replace old titles all we
discussed all types of there was an
english wars with russian wars
so we are russian it was some kind of
resurrection of all of these feelings
and then 1999 nato bombings
again it was a kind it was a feeling of
um even in the middle class it was a
feeling of of betrayal
and serbia yes it was so strange to see
to all these planes and you remember
primakov he returned his plane and he
was supported by population so
uh
we might predict uh that
something like putin might come and
because many friends start to talk well
maybe we need some some
some kind who might be similar to peanut
chad and this idea of peanut sheet
became very very popular
well i think so that's why
maybe putin is not divorced that we can
anticipate in 1999 in 2000
uh and today what we can understand that
maybe now parents and maybe we our
generation will fought
and many of them many of us fought
in the early 1990s was uh but all that
we
what we really
wanted from the west just
luxury things and private freedoms
freedom to gain to to make money freedom
to
to go abroad
and
to have our i don't know apartments in
spain
but not
not not public freedoms it looks like
for many it was question
not very important
and i think personally that we got in
the in the mid and the late 1990s
really great medias and we we and maybe
population
didn't deserve these medias
because to be frank nobody was very
interested to to read these papers
in the 1990s we have commerce and we we
have only one hundred thousand
circulation
while ten years after that we have
conversant and we have one hundred
thousand circulation just the same
figure so we we have an increased middle
class but just the same number of uh of
of readers for for this maybe
the only one
uh professional newspaper in the country
because it's really professional daily
maybe the only one but people not well
i'm not very interested to read it
so to be frank i'm quite
i'm not a big optimist i think that if
uh
if if if
i i don't understand how to create this
idea for the for the for the people but
that you need your public freedoms
because it's look for for many we are
quite happy with private things
well
and maybe uh there are some ideas but
maybe if
there would be economic crisis and
circumstances
around the country might change for
example the
oil prices might change so maybe it
might provoke population to think uh and
to to to to act but for me i think that
well they might they might start to be
more active but in this way maybe we can
be more
my maybe we can decide that we need more
strict picture
maybe we can decide not to to go to to
the west but to to go to china for
example because the idea of china
uh was quite popular in uh in the in the
early 2000s now they mostly forgot about
china but wow they might talk about
it every time so you think i'm not very
big optimistic
hi so because of the crisis of investiga
investigative journalism in russia we
have now clear picture of what really
happened happens in russia
in general uh because many process are
not clear and i think that uh they could
have a hope uh because right now the
station in russia looks like a
stagnation but it might it might
it might be changed very quickly because
of uh different circumstances as the
first of economical situation in the
world and russia i think and so i think
um
we can have uh we can have russians who
might be more active
in
in
foreign media and and
in publishing
era
mitsya wirth i'm with the naval
postgraduate school i i'd like to sort
of carry on from
from peter's question i'd like to get
some sense of what you think your
generation
kind of across the country how they feel
about this and also
are you having the same problem that
we're having which is this large number
of people who are unemployed and is that
related to any of of the issues that
you're dealing with
to befriend our generation
is very successful because we were born
in the soviet union we know that rules
might change we are not so
obedient to
uh and they care about more active more
more mobile so that's why mostly if we
are talking with our friends who are not
journalists we are very successful we
are very successful lawyers or
businessman or bankers uh it's a problem
with them
but
by 35 they
started to feel that well
okay i got my family i got my my my
house my mansion all these things what
to do next and they started to be very
close to this problems of their own
families
so they tend to think mostly about these
things they don't don't want to think
maybe it's because it's not very
effective to be frank to think about
politics in russia it's not very
well it might prevent your good career
so why to do it
for many it's uh a big challenge and we
just don't need don't want to talk about
these things and that's it's one of the
problem that we
almost lost
a
public discussion about the most
important things nobody wants to talk
about enough caucuses nobody wants to
talk about
a new initiative of motivation to
suppress um
troublemakers by new technical system of
servants and
all these things that was
launched just two years ago well for
many well
we are quite secure yes there's some
some terrorist attacks might happen in
moscow well it's it happens okay but we
uh
yes
we don't want to think about it so do
you think that when your generation is
50 and not 35
that you're going to just carry on the
same stuff or will will they think about
opening it up
well
that's a big question from for us it's a
very big and open question i just don't
know maybe there's some people who might
be more active in in some years but to
be frank i'm not
i i think that if you want to to be
active in politics you need to start
1935 but in 21-22
but and the idea is not to forget about
it afterwards for many many of my
friends and we have some very good
friends lawyers who who are very active
in that
might be quite older 37 38 they were
very active in the late 80s they took
part in manifestations and demonstration
now they pressured them both to take
part in some manifestation in the mosque
or mostly in support of uh killed
journalists or killed lawyers well they
might end with manifestation about uh in
the name of killed players but it would
be quite about this thing but not about
for example we have
a number of manifestations just for open
speech of open sp uh in favor of open
speech for one of these ideas to
abstract
well okay
uh thank you my name is gregory smallov
i'm a former correspondent for
commercial in november
and currently a researcher of russian
internet at george washington university
you wrote a few very interesting pieces
about russian internet and fsb and the
conversion between hacker groups and usb
a few years ago
so i wonder what is the current state of
uh all the related to internet
activities of fsb and what extent have a
lot of urban legends about whatever's
been doing in the internet so do they
have the right tools to follow
everything what type of activities are
they doing now and what is the current
state of fsb internet uh
russian block surfings
and uh i would add there's a chapter on
the subject in the book so i call your
attention to please
uh
uh in fact the fsb was quite smart to
keep distance with hackers so it's not
the fsb who attacked the foreign
websites uh there's a number of people
and according to our information their
support not directly by the fsb
but the kremlin so it's the same we can
compare the situation with youth
movements like nashee and uh
and the maladai guardian and some people
some bloggers are recruited from from
from from the ranks of office youth
organizations and just are supervised by
by the same people in the administration
what the f is be done firstly they
encouraged this activity when something
happened and and
for example we had
a very famous attack when some students
and two tried to attack kafka center in
the united states uh there was
complaints and there was call to local
fsb office to ask wall you have his
students what
uh they said well uh these students were
they just patriots so we have nothing to
do with them they were just patriots
pitchers yes
they're just pictures and they that's
ah so that's why we don't need to to
prosecute them and now as far as as they
see and we noticed this and
once that the fsb tried to find a way to
to some groups of of hackers
uh to again but
not to pay them not to order them but to
encourage them because sometimes it's it
would be enough because in this case
they might keep this distance and
you see it was it turned to it turned
out to be very successful in in case of
estonia tony tried to accuse russian
state but because we can't find the
evidences well
it's uh again we have we have to talk
only about just russian hackers
and uh
let's let's answer
and uh uh a few words about blogosphere
but it seems that
blog
that the
secret service is not very active in
blogsphere because of it's an an area of
uh presidential administration they
cover all this yeah and they have
special comments who are uh who works in
blogosphere and have the and special
persons who have their their own blogs
and so so they even created the cr so
called kremlin's school of bloggers yeah
burton gerber georgetown university
um could you say a few words about the
relationship
between fsb and svr
and for instance
when we're talking about the or when the
russians are talking about the near
abroad
which organization has primacy
in looking at that
and to what extent there is subversion
sponsored by one or the other
organizations in the near abroad for
instance the great interest in georgia
or ukraine
the fsb
uh
was given a very special task and
in in
karnataka
out operations in abroad they will ask
you to task it to
to supervise a former soviet union
and they now have a special department
called the department of operative
information and they're mostly
responsible for dealing with former
soviet republics including
estonia and alberta states
but the problem is that
because there is no mechanism of even
internal control this department because
of some bureaucratic reasons
uh
began to increase the activity
and sometimes for journalists you have
to deal with very peculiar things to to
to understand what's going on inside
well after i might say that now this
department adopted new insignia and now
it's a globe
and at the same time the foreign
intelligence the svr
as we understood uh also was just
recently was tasked to deal with the
former soviet union republics and um
this july
uh the special website appeared uh
uh on the internet called lubenska
pravda are true for blanca.com
and
it existed only three weeks but there
was a number of documents and
to my opinion i had no ability to check
them but as far as i can say they looked
incredible
there were some documents about some
operations of the fsb and ukraine and
there was very interesting notes
uh top secret to the president of
russian federation uh from the director
department of operative security
of activity uh we carry out this special
operation in ukraine we
may we created false document to present
it to the government of ukraine
and we have to say that the foreign
intelligence service they grabbed this
document and reported it to moscow as
genuine so we we ask you politely to say
our
our colleagues that it's fake
so andre they're competing in other
words yes
christopher schroeder friend of davids
um
history is filled with unintended
consequences and i'm sort of curious if
you could play back with the fsb has
become and if you could interview putin
10 years ago
is this what he wanted and is he stuck
in any way in things that he never
thought would happen once these things
become unleashed and second question if
i could could you and i'm sure it's in
the book could you just give us a quick
tour of who to watch
in these organizations who are the
people we're going to be hearing about
in the next five to 10 years and you
know who they are
um
i think because putin made some
interview and the 2019 99
and he was quite honest i think he
anticipates something different
because he wanted to create real new
elite for russia a kind of junta united
by common perspectives on russian
present and future people loyal to the
kremlin obedient
to his daughter who would be the kind of
vanguard
of the russians in the russian state
but in fact you know that in 2007 it
became even public
um
the big struggle between people inside
the secret services against each other
and there is an open letter published by
commerce and
uh written by excuse me by victor kesev
former
kgb officer are responsible for
political surveillance and then the
chief of antarctic agency a close friend
of putin who said that well now various
become
traders
so i think we now it has been uh now
putin quite disappointed by this this
internal crisis because uh he
as well as far as we know he's fully
aware of it because he even tasked the
agency of victor cherkessev to
to investigate the activity of the
leadership of the fsb and the anti-drug
agency failed and some
general and a general from the anti-drug
agency who was responsible for his
investigation was centered to jail
well so i think he's not quite happy
with what now he have it has but
at the same time i think
he might be happy that um in the 1990s
one of the big problems for the
government officials was you have to
face all these questions from foreign
journalists from domestic journalists
and you have to answer these questions
maybe honestly might be not the problem
is what's happened to today when the
political culture became so secretive
and so suspicious but now if you ask
official first of all it would be very
difficult to ask him because you need to
find him
uh and then the second question is but
if you ask the question the answer would
be not the answer to the question but to
a kind of
search for
who paid you for this question who
ordered you to ask this question
and i think that that what happened in
in the 2000s and i think putin because
you know he has a very strange habit to
answer questions he's quite happy with
that
okay
delphine shrank of the east west centre
i had a question about um
who is resisting in society the sort of
the the
the the
uh the difficulty
of um pushing back against
the freedoms and the political uh
restrictions aside from the mass
stagnation surely there are people in
addition to the investigative
journalists who are trying different
sectors of society who who is doing that
and what kind of pressures are on them
uh we have an activity of some local
small groups uh who
um who are mostly about some local
problems uh if they neighbor with uh for
example the force around them or
they have for example they have some pro
some very active trade unions in some
cities where there is a big plants and
so these people they are very angry
about
but the problems with uh
with a
leadership ever try to
uh to do something the problem is that
we are now we are the subject of
of the campaign against extremism and
this campaign was mostly launched not by
putin but by medvedev because medvedev
in 2008
uh
created the new he disbanded the
department
responsible for fighting organized crime
and terrorism in the interior ministry
and in the same place he created the new
department
uh
responsible for fighting extremism
and it was set openly that now we've won
our war against russian mafia there is
not asthma affair today it was
officially claimed
uh well and now all these thousands of
experienced officers and the interior
ministry who were responsible for for
penetrating criminal groups or terrorist
cells they now responsible for dealing
with this kind of troublemakers so now
we have in there we have a lot a lot of
example when trade union activists would
be
uh ask you to go to the local office of
center
on fighting extremism and would be said
well you are
kind of uh the activity is provocative
you try to to undermine russian state
and you might be accused and
there's a number of examples when
bloggers who criticized the activity of
the foreign of the federal security
service and the interim ministry were
accused
against the same thing in extremism
so mostly it's um it's about
bloggers and the local groups
and we have and maybe some small very
not very significant liberal political
organizations like for example kasparov
liberal movement
which is to be frank is very small and
even in best days it would might govern
only two thousand or two or three
thousand people
that's that's my
but we are subject of of um
uh of the investigation of this big
department and quite recently two months
ago the fsb asked for new powers
uh and we were given the spouse
and
medvedev
science in europe
giving the fsb
more powers to
to prevent the crimes of extremism and
for me it's very very
i just i'm not very
sure what did what does it mean because
extremism in russia it's something about
wards it's not about actions it's not
about attacks or
bombings it's about what you say
something that might might be
provocative
well and to prevent
someone to say something that might be
provocative well i think it's very murky
area but now the fsb was given the right
so now two big services in their
ministry and the federal service uh they
deal with
small numbers of troublemakers
okay first year and then we'll go to the
back okay
hello andre and irina i'm lauren
mandeville from the french daily
newspaper figaro i've spent a few years
in russia myself and
i was struck by what you said about the
um the fact that
nobody really knows what's going on in
russia because you know
investigative journalism is
nearly dead i mean apart from a few
exceptions like you trying to fight
against the current
and i was wondering if you would extend
this notion to the fact that
in the west
uh
people are less and less
less and less know what's going on in
russia as well i mean there used to be a
very big
current of information about russia
in europe and in the us and
and you can really see now that it's not
the case that there's less and less
information about what's really going on
throughout russia so do you feel somehow
intellectually and politically abandoned
in your effort to grasp
was where is your country going
and in connection with that first
question i was wondering what you think
of um
the current foreign policy of of the
west and both obama administration and
people like
president sarkozy and
what is your feeling about what the west
is doing now with russia
the first of our investigative
journalism in russia ah
yes of course we feel feel yourself
a little bit abundant by the
intellectuals and
we have
we failed to attract attention of the
authorities and change some things that
we investigate we can publish the
investigations and nobody pay attention
uh or sometimes it might be some
possible actions against us for example
some criminal cases or interrogations
but um generally nobody pay attention to
to works of uh to our investigations
but so
and uh the situation is that uh
the paper
the leadership of the paper have no
interest to publish papers have no
interest to publish investigations
because of to avoid the problem and if
you're talking about foreign governments
i think that
well it was a surprise for us because
and um it's one of the big big problems
uh big issues of the book that we tried
to write about right and that in the
early 2000s in the late 1990s we fought
and many dissidents and russian experts
fought
but we see a kind of
kgb revival and this and this new power
putin might change the whole country and
economic rules and country
but in fact what was what we saw and i
think that might be the answer because
my
because the west sees the same thing
that
fsb was not so active they were given
the powers they never tried to gain the
power
and
something some some crucial things
changed but
political culture economic rules we have
the same thing we have the same
oligarchs even the same names
uh
no there is no talks about uh
about uh property rights
um
um
except some crucial things uh
there is some guarantees for for
investors uh putin was very very
generous with the united states just
after 1990 uh just after 9 11 attacks uh
he even closed down some intelligence
facilities
for example lord base in
in cuba very close to united states and
and he closed down the base the
intelligence facility in in vietnam
well
that's just a problem of of of russian
uh it looks like for the west way
because we're quite happy with foreign
policy
of russian state except some exceptions
like georgia but to be frank it was
well i think everybody understood it was
not a question but
if you are talking about even iran you
see that medvedev is very very generous
i'll write to bob about
it's not like it's
everybody understood i think even even
in the west that uh
putin's state is not
a kind of um
new russian new soviet state created in
1920s with the idea of commentary on the
revolution everywhere and to undermine
the regimes in every country we are not
so big fred just a country will we have
some strange habits to deal with
internal opposition but it's just
problem of internal position
you mean will it be published in russian
yeah published in russian and so
very very well what do you think is
there a chance this book would be
published in russia yeah i think so
because now we not v but public office
has some uh talks with our russian uh
publishing house and we're
[Laughter]
has there been a reaction to the book
inside of russia um
official no there is no official
reaction and
there was one interview at rajasthan
again
radio free refrigerator and um russian
service of the bbc but that's all it
looks like well it's to be frank it's
very smart because
uh the story would be would be
a big story only if other papers for
example commercial might pick up this
story but
mostly
other papers might pick up the store
only if there's a government reaction in
this case it would be a story if you
just publish something well it's you
it's your choice
we had one question on the back here
thank you uh ill also in freedom house
uh you have mentioned earlier that in
1990s when there was a creation of the
fsb as we know it's now it sort of
toppled the influence of svr and uh gado
and other agencies
my question is regarding the north
caucasus of which no one wants to talk
about in russia um how much competition
is going um
in controlling uh the situation between
the guru and fsb and the qadhari militia
units as i understand guru sort of has
been squeezed out and qatar has tried to
squeeze out the fsb as well but um
not quite exactly so who is exactly
controlling the situation in chechnya
and other republics
uh especially given the
a new spike in a militant activity and
the split in the militants
i think
so can we explain what gru
yeah the problem is that in fact the fsb
uh
[Music]
used their powers
and uh
this
regime
and the powers and the powers and um
and the critical and the way and
the trust that you currently put on them
uh not to obtain more responsibility in
the enough caucuses but to avoid it
uh we have as you know uh as a country
terrorism oppression in chechnya for 10
years officially it started in 1999 and
ended in april 19 2009 but the fsb was
responsible for for the operation
only for 31 months and it was 1 2003 and
it was long before kadyrov
so the idea of the fsb was to
to have a free hand in chechnya to use
shoot and kill policy to have this squad
where but not to take responsibility
that's why the responsibilities were
handed over to the interior ministry and
mostly to enter on troops and now the
internal troops are most active force
and
and in the enough caucus it's not only
in uh for example in dagestan the same
situation in kabardin balkari and the
appointment of roponium changed nothing
in this situation he still
think that says internal troops are the
most effective force to deal with
terrorists so that's why it was not the
struggle between military intelligence
fsb and uh
and internal troops for control in fact
the internal troops were given his right
and fsb was quite high perfect what what
kadyrov uh why cardiff is so important
because sometimes because now
we have this new soft district and uh
halaponia is officially responsible for
the situation and not only for the
situation and
an economic area but for for the whole
situation and he was given
people just the same people who who sat
in khan kala and who start to be
controlled by kadyrov so it's look like
now if you're talking about security
things
happening
controlled by kadyrov and this is the
problem but but for for the fsb well
they carry out some very good operations
with ya we killed some people they even
detained one prominent leader but they
don't want to be responsible
and and for military intelligence
because we because we now have a very
big
reform of uh the ministry of defense and
many specs nazi units including us not
brigade which is stationed and rostov
um is a situation that they might be
disbanded completely so they are just
not in positions to do something in
chechnya or in the enough caucuses
uh being being honest to the fsb uh we
should say that this year uh the fsb
special forces was active in the north
caucasus and the special forces of the
fsb uh organized few
uh successful liquidation of terrorists
and one man was captured uh it was
a big success for them because they
didn't do it
okay i got two more questions one
[Music]
bill tucker uh i worked in the reagan
administration and and the white house
counsel's office
and i have uh
talked to
elect valenza bachelor pavel michael
klaus
our fed gonce former president of
hungary
uh
the prime minister of the slovak
republic
and
reagan came into office and one of his
goals was to
bring down the soviet union and he
referred to it as you know as an evil
empire
and to to a man
all of these uh leaders in the former
warsaw pac countries
have said that
reagan calling
the soviet union and evil empire
gave them the courage and the
inspiration to fight on against
communism
and but i would like to know from your
viewpoint
what effect
your reagan
and the west had on the pressure they
brought
on the soviet union to bring
bring down the soviet debt union and
cause it to fail
oh i think you know that the
the biggest
address of the idea that
the west was very important in uh
and
in um
in this bunny the soviet union was the
kgb personnel and
former kgb
uh
chief yurikuchikov and
many other generals they constantly
talked to press and said well there are
so many so-called agents of influence of
the west in our government so that's why
the soviet union collapsed but in fact i
think that we exaggerated the
importance
and the role of of of the west because
dissidence groups were very small
and undropper for so harsh to persecute
them but by the
mid 1990s and mid 1980s they became so
insignificant
and there was no support from the from
the population to them i think it was
mostly
it
uh this well of course our
for example are my parents listen to to
to radio for voice of american but well
for
it's it never provoked them to to do
something to to to be to become active
so jessica okay we can we can listen to
it well that's that's that's great this
might be
interesting to hear some some voices of
of socialism for example but it was not
so so significant i think it's mostly
was internal crisis
just and mostly because and i think the
role of gorbachev was very very
important it was his decision but
because i think that if gerbach decided
not to do
all these things
well it might last for another 10 years
maybe 15 years
it was his decision and and some
uh some people close to him but again
it's i should be very cautious because i
i when i was very young i was not a
journalist so i have no ability to check
all this thing
okay last question here in the back
my name is samar chatterjee from safe
foundation i have a question
regarding the
uh
fsb
i have all read that
even in hitler's time the person who
headed up their secret service or his
his own
secret service shellin
schellenberg he was collecting
information on hitler to overthrow him
in whenever an opportunity came
uh same in the united states you know we
there is a suspicion that a fbi or i
like to call these uh so-called
intelligence agencies agencies of state
terrorism and that exists in every
country whether it's in russia or in the
united states or anywhere else
they probably knocked off kennedy
and those kinds of things do happen and
then we saw bush senior push who was a
cia
chief his son becoming a president so
that
is there something going on to either
knock off medvedev and putin together or
there may be an adversarial relationship
at some point and one of them will
overthrow that
something like that is happening or some
third person like what happened to
khrushchev will come and
boom overthrow these two guys
i think if you are talking about
sensitive information collected by the
fsb about i don't know mid video for
putin i think we had some examples but
already only in the 1990s when we have
korzakov who collected
uh information he published it and there
was but i think that if
there should be reason for this thing
and the first thing is that you have to
have public opinion and very
strong medias to publish this stuff
because on the media my if you probably
if you have a strong media they might
publish all this stuff so it's my result
and resignation of some senior officials
today if you even have some very
sensitive stuff about some very high
placed officials well there is no reason
to publish it because nobody would be
it's just not a
no
well we see even but
it it was never used for for 10 years
except this
last example of a major mayor of moscow
luzkoff but it was first it was decision
of midway if he was not
um he was not
pressured by media to do this thing he
decided to he just yeah
yeah he was just
yeah and if you are talking about how
how putin is uh controlled by the fsb i
think it's a big question
for me because i think that if you have
no possibility to check information
dependently if you're president and you
have no independent channels if you have
no media you have no parliament uh
independent parliament you have no so
you can create many many police as
napoleon done or try to do ah
or it was decision of yields and but if
you have only one main secret police and
uh well it's the only source of
information for you so you would be very
quickly influenced by this sort of
information and for you it's very
difficult to to find new decisions and
to be not
pressured by them well i think it's a
big question both for media for putin
okay well listen i'd like to thank
everybody for coming i i'm having read
the book myself i'd like to call your
attention the fact that there's a lot of
juicy material in this book that we
haven't talked about today and uh what
definitely is worth an afternoon of your
time there's a particularly three very
strong chapters about how the fsb dealt
with terrorism in the in the last decade
there's a very thoughtful bit about the
fsb and the rule of law
there's some very good material about
the role of the fsb in the political
process and certainly um with dissidents
and they're one of my favorite small
gems in this book is a chapter really
about the moscow secret subway and i
won't give it away but i hope you get a
chance to read it so thanks everybody
for coming i'm sure the authors will
hang around
and answer your questions and thanks
again to foreign policy and the new
america foundation for giving this this
chance
[Music]
this event was hosted by the new america
foundation in washington d.c
for more information visit
newamerica.net